Yeah.
What are some of the [inaudible]?
A gay one. Oh, can you ask that?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
personality professional is a
[inaudible] a [inaudible]
Pedro [inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible]
yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] you know,
you know
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] there's one of my
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
no matter fund.
What is it?
That game game can be thought out.
Eat that had been [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] spiny dorsal.
We're simply that,
but then there's Mucho [inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] e
and as opposed to the,
the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] going to
take us in the morning if I'm in a
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and then low.
And they think
it's cute. When I got about, um,
Eh,
again, it's usually been
Montenegro metal. Yeah.
You go to [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
if we are,
I fell at home and then
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] because
you can master tech was, uh,
was, uh, no, I'm in contaminate.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] and [inaudible].
Most Doritos and
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] I get another,
you know it.
Just tell me
[inaudible] [inaudible]
environmental polo.
So just go more [inaudible]
eh,
I pull up
[inaudible].
Yeah, yeah. Hit me. You
know that, Eh, Israel gay.
I don't always feel good.
Didn't want to be rude. That
[inaudible]
and
[inaudible] [inaudible] island to castle
a Sweden [inaudible] commerce to Bertha
Thier Norberto I [inaudible]
the [inaudible] story.
I want to [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] is a [inaudible]
score like Athena,
the ancillary Amanda
after I woke up at
this. Yeah. Yes. And the
[inaudible],
the [inaudible] [inaudible]
for [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
in the nano then [inaudible] it's
fundamentally,
it's important that all those horses
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Yana
and [inaudible] was he?
Yes. Yes, yes. [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] locale.
There is quantum PFS DNS collateral.
We cloud on the
[inaudible] [inaudible] the
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
There's the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] dot
com or [inaudible] here is fundamental
[inaudible].
Hey,
[inaudible] Julio
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] we go more.
We went on to [inaudible] [inaudible]
you see him?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Oh,
as the Kentucky,
they feel no stress bill.
This isn't it.
You should get a cookie.
[inaudible] declare hello.
Or they can mush
collateral they do when their toes
to toes facet. That's positive.
I see the [inaudible] a [inaudible]
the [inaudible] one of [inaudible]
Eh
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
competitively. Then the rest persona,
she mucho Mucho course.
Okay.
Just give [inaudible] even conduct
you a menu of the areas and new CTO.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] personnel.
I'll let you do [inaudible] a
[inaudible] [inaudible] video mass,
Eh, bestow into canal is a split gas. Uh,
Bruno [inaudible] Como up in this,
the [inaudible] is [inaudible].
We're was the diameter three hall
a nominated doing she the NATO
NATO
[inaudible] [inaudible] and my
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] three is the Labia.
I mean,
maybe
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and then they
get, they get this year, you know,
there's a number,
so we opinions or [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] is there that you maybe,
and we got to tell you [inaudible] he's,
you know, if my neighbor, you understand?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] everywhere. Ra. Yeah.
This totally libido, you know,
didn't [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I want
to turn and they're going to face
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and she's
in a way around it, no matter. Yeah,
get rid of that, eh, I'd be
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] e
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
is Kate [inaudible]
noble. Give me a couple of
hundred [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
are they [inaudible]?
Can I
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] yes.
Thank God,
but not that much of a
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] with,
is he an experience here in Cleveland?
Is it
the
[inaudible]?
That's the spreading of the
ESR
kissing.
I've got a whole plethora of
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] s
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] no,
Eh,
they got a phone in order to
establish [inaudible] taking me down.
[inaudible] he
does.
What are your [inaudible] need?
Eh?
[inaudible] not that noise.
[inaudible] yes.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
is throwing [inaudible]
Publico [inaudible] I know it
was Hal [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] don't even know.
Well,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] motto.
[inaudible] you are asked
to [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
he must've so much, eh.
[inaudible] you [inaudible]
I'm someone that Amy
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
button.
They were up on
owning your solo.
Eric
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and
nobody's here.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
don't [inaudible] in the attorneys to
[inaudible] eh?
[inaudible] Fondo No.
As soon as [inaudible] they didn't,
they Khalida usually the oak.
You told me she was able to work on
your case from [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] we can most another
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] just
tell us I'm [inaudible] mystical your
India gap.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] professional
[inaudible] [inaudible] is
that the Basso who are Howard
[inaudible] disc is full of it
almost is owner of her birth.
Your [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] so it's
not there today, but, oh no,
it's [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
I think
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] like after Laura
his mouth [inaudible] no.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I'm talking about,
you know why you come on with
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] a [inaudible] a
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] um,
no.
These
Bordeaux and the mask and [inaudible] no.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Oh, you're [inaudible] think we're
going to what? You want to be in south
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] area.
I said no,
he over the [inaudible] cannot
DNA complicative [inaudible] using
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] yes.
[inaudible].